[Musique]
en direct du canada
cette entame canada qui vous parle bien
de montréal là je vais dire la capitale
économique
non il faut être un trait là-dessus
depuis 30 ans une des deux grandes
villes canadiennes
la deuxième en importance pour tout et
je pars pour dire des méchants ce rire
de montréal très belle ville ensoleillée
depuis plusieurs jours c'est l'été comme
ça se poursuit au mois d'août avec mes
collègues de radio canada international
c'est bien sûr la fête c'est le vendredi
alors fantastique on va le sentir
vendredi aujourd'hui parce que j'allais
lors du tour euh ah bon ouais bah oui
parce que moi je suis debout parce que
les sièges sont trop hauts pour moi
alors le vendredi c'est un de ces pas ça
prendrait une petite musique un peu plus
à la body soul des années 80 on se
croirait au limelight à montréal avait
connu non plus c'est un bar et chaque
étage avait son allure
c'est à dire qu'il y avait un étage pour
ceux qui préfèrent les hommes ou les
femmes tient même jour où un car pour
les hétérosexuels
donc c'était très ouvert et pour les
chats ce qui peut faire des choix moi
j'adore les chats raymond des marteaux
et là bonjour marie jobin également bon
filon aucune idée encore une fois quel
est le sujet de notre émission c sauf
moi c'est vrai
moi j'allais sur un peu sans vouloir le
savoir mais bon je participerai pas
prendre monsieur d'accord alors y'a pas
de jeu c'est juste on a besoin d'une
vidéo
ceux qui nous regardent peuvent
également s'amuser avec nous mais y'a
rien à perdre mais plutôt qu'elle avait
pas de question
oh il ya pas de questions ok bah y voir
des questions durant l'émission mais là
pour savoir le sujet de l'émission vous
poser des questions
c'est avec toi on y va on présentait
cinq images des mousses anti que sur la
piste ne faut pas attendre le premier
qui lèvent la main
je viens devant qui s'arrête aujourd'hui
on regarde ces cinq images on appelle ça
la vidéo 5 images
chaque semaine c'est la tradition à tan
tan canada première image
les endroits où il ya eu des tueries aux
états unis au ghana ou au canada il dit
il
ces cinq-là drusian on est sur une piste
intéressante à un beau chien
oui des morsures de chiens aux attaques
non oui des morsures ça c'est là dessus
que dans la fameuse maladie de lyme en
pl maladie de lyme vous avez est ce que
ça vous est déjà arrivé d'avoir ça sur
le saut vous ce nom je pense que non
oui sur le chien le chien ah oui ok moi
j'y vois si je dis oui à prendre ma
douche garde s'est enfoui et le bain je
me suis rendu à l'urgence j'ai essayé de
l'enlever mais ça restait l'un puis à
l'urgence le monsieur me dit le médecin
m'a dit vous auriez pas dû essayer de
l'enlever avec une pince à épiler
ça reste encore à l'intérieur et sa peau
conçue et mise à la retraite en était
rien compris
ptc pas ça c'est qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour arriver d'avoir à lui que
j'adore javel ou encore bureau de
médecin il ya en fait deux nouvelles
spéciales pas tout la bête et ensuite
des médicaments des tests vous donnez
antibiotiques dans les heures qui
suivent ou même encore 24 heures sur 24
heures
puis on n'essaiera pas de problème une
pilule moi ça suffit une pilule pour ya
pas de problème jusqu'à maintenant c'est
une vraie moi j'étais du bon pendant un
jour et demi j'avais pas pris de douche
la fin de twitter ça sentait pas bon
histoire et les détails il ya trois ans
j'étais appelé le patient zéro dans la
communauté j'habite à l'hôpital le
premier de l'année au mois de mars
la voix alors ils ont pu faire une
enquête pour savoir si c'était si elles
étaient infectées par la maladie de lyme
je vous ai dit jeudi à l'émission
aujourd'hui le 10ème vous le comprendrez
oui tout à fait parce que j'ai tendance
à avoir lu ça plutôt que de l'avoir
entendu d'abord et moins la même c'était
l'hymne en tout cas pour l'inciteront
avec ça
non non et puis écoutez j'ai quelque
chose pour vous pour s'amuser un peu
c'est tellement triste la vie les voir
on va rire alors premier tour de la
grosse boule lyonnaise patron par
émission vous avez combien de boue à la
peine pour ce premier tour st écoutez
c'est pas aussi facile qu'on le pense
ça y est on affiche la première question
alors première question voici où la
maladie de lyme est elle présente vous
avez un choix de réponse comme
d'habitude dont vous êtes les étudiants
à europe b asie c'est amérique du nord
ou des tous les continents
moi je dirais c'est américain amérique
du nord pour la maladie de lyme c'est là
où elle est présente
maryse non gérées avec m moi aussi
vous aussi ça veut dire quoi regina a
bien du mal à vous aussi amérique du
nord d'accord c'est donc c'est non il me
semble qu'il y en a en europe on sait
qu'ils en amérique du nord
donc j'irai vers tous les continents
mais je ne suis pas trop sur jésus je
vais quand même essayer tous les
continents
vous perdez vos points les droits tous
les deux à tous les continents
principalement en amérique en europe et
la russie mais c'est dans les régions
d'or bien en afrique maintenant au maroc
je pense qu'ils ont autant des textes en
asie c'est partout moi je suis pas un
spécialiste de ça bien sûr on avait
toujours un spécialiste à l'émission
pour en parler
je veux voir là si on est prêt ou on est
prêts me dit en tout cas la tour de
contrôle ont fermé tôt oui enfin bien
sinon somme est aveuglant voilà alors
première éviter aujourd'hui sur cette
question de santé publique qui touche
beaucoup de nos auditeurs en europe en
ce moment et on commande voit maintenant
en afrique du nord
françois miller est professeur agrégé au
département des sciences de santé
communautaire il est à l'université de
sherbrooke
est-ce que je dois dire docteur millar
oui je pense
ça va je suis médecin elle ment voilà
vous êtes même médecin conseil pour la
région de santé de votre région et vous
y êtes un des experts québécois
sur cette question la maladie de lyme de
l'udm je vais parler un peu de l'europe
parce que moi je fait des années que je
parle de sauces depuis six ans je m'y
intéresse j'habite à la campagne c'est
normal mais je ne savais pas que ça
existait en europe j'ai appris ça cette
semaine cela je me dis beaucoup de
choses qu'on sait pas au sujet de cette
maladie quel est le portrait de la
maladie au plan mondial commençons par
ça ensuite on réduira vers l'amérique du
nord et canada
alors en fait henri la tequila mai et
d'un équipement tempérer ce qui veut
dire qu'on la trouve en amérique à en
eux et un peu hein si on rate un peu le
pas et pèse davantage en alors pour ce
qui est des états unis bien on va en
parler
elle vient leucate convient-il de
milliers de cas dans le monde
donnez-nous une idée une idée moi j'ai
lu quelque part cette semaine du dépôt
cru
c'était pas une source de radio canada
négocie bisseni de bbc c'était en europe
65000 kg ça parce que c'est impossible
c'était un homme s'y est pas en fait aux
états unis on parle de et en aura
probablement soi et la situation au
canada
quelle est elle au canada on pas lu
milka avanies en 2010
donc on est au tour de 2004 la majorité
et en ontario et benguela 2000 qu'a donc
en tout c'est une maladie qui est
souvent associée à un animal qui porter
de l'attique le cerf de virginie
est-ce que c'est toujours cet animal qui
peut transmettre qui peut promener
l'attique d'un endroit à un autre
ou est ce qu'elle se promène seule elle
peut vagabonder
en fait ce qui est minime et dont elle
ne peut pas se pâmer peur elle est
déplacée sur des cours du temps tu as
raisons exposées longue passe par les
eaux parce qu'elle va piquer outils des
oiseaux et c'est une des raids ont la
peau et les oiseaux me jean d'autres
questions ces animaux là que porteur de
la tic sont infectés j'imagine par la
maladie ou même aussi ou en fait le le
principal et ses microbes donc de la
mairie de sonder petit en région boisée
et les oiseaux également aimé l'espère
de vies humaines et résistant là et ont
tant qu'ils ne
il ne contient pas le club athènes fera
mais les chasse avant de peut consommer
alors que pour l'humain c'est sérieux il
ya un drapeau rouge
oui tout à fait les les animaux dont on
a parlé ne développe pas vraiment de ça
mais l'humain bien sûr peut développer
différents symptômes dont plusieurs
stades et une avec le tarn est prêté
parlez nous un peu de commun on
reconnaît maintenant cette maladie parce
que pendant longtemps on hésitait à
diagnostiquer les gens atteints de la
maladie de lyme
si on parle de vous avez présent non
plus de dix ans narnia nazis n'étaient
pas connus par les armes mais depuis dix
ans le nom les lakers ont sur eux
et effectivement on peut être et aux
différents stades mais on se prête bien
aux premiers stades qui hélas labo que
vous avez vus nus sur des halles alors
de plus en plus les maîtres ès compte
sensibiliser dit impatient compte japon
sur le haut et cette voix républicaines
qui ont fait le diagnostic on peut
presque dans les plus tu avances et
faire des années et c'est plus
facilement ce que je m'en acheter c'est
plus facilement traitable au début de la
maladie
oui oui c'est plus facilement le pense
le traitement de plus pour durer il ya
moins de moins de risque de conserver
son titre et elle vous que ça prenne du
coeur semaine que tous les cinq ans
maintenant on est traité au mieux
évidemment mieux c'est je vais
m'adresser à la table c'est ce que je
même problème que s quelle leçon nous
arrive de façon saccadée bien qu'en
perdre a dit celle-là
alors écoutez on ne poursuivra pas
beaucoup plus longtemps cette entrevue
professeurs nous avons eu notre invité
d'ailleurs qui voudraient se joindre à
la conversation
je vous pose une dernière question est
ce que au niveau du traitement
il ya des différents courants penser il
n'y a pas une bataille en ce moment
entre des façon différente d'aborder la
question pour savoir comment pas
seulement diagnostic mais comment le
comment traiter les gens qui sont
atteints de cette maladie je pense que
le débat s'est prouvé que les personnes
y étaient donc une avancée de la ville
ou des symptômes qui dure depuis plus
longtemps ou là la question
la durée du traitement que la majorité
des médecins m'ont dit qu'ils puissent
passer sur des études c'est que les
traitements de plus de un à deux mois ça
ne sert à rien ça ne rajoute pas à la
guérison
alors que certaines pourquoi je vous
reconnais des traitements depuis des
mois voire une année ou deux mais les
études n'ont pas montré très efficace et
lyon en balanche des traitements lui il
ya des faits secondaires alors c'est un
talent du rythme très bien professeur
vie leur merci beaucoup de nous avoir
aidés à mettre la table aujourd'hui puis
bonne poursuite de réflexion et d'études
sur cette maladie qui devient vraiment
un problème international présentement
merci merci au revoir françois miller
docteur françois miller un peu décevant
que la communication technique ya un
petit défaut on comprenait bien quand on
y arrive est très claire alors écoutez
deuxième tour de la grosse boule oui
vous êtes prêts pour la perte de combien
31.1 bull maryse a gardé toutes ces
boules
bien sûr comme d'habitude à la voix si
cette question deuxième question
deuxième tout
on va lire ça ensemble oui voilà dans
combien de cas sur dix la piqûre de la
tique pastel inaperçu parce que ça c'est
un gros problème de santé publique
contre ça passera pas qu'on a été piquée
on ne choisit pas d'aller vers un
médecin ou d'aller à l'urgence est là la
maladie peut progresser alors dans
combien de cas sur dix la piqûre de la
tique pastel inaperçu dans le cas de la
maladie
la transmission de la maladie de lyme s
à 2 à 3 fois sur 10 ha ce b 4 à 5 fois
sur dix ouais c'est 6 à 7 fois sur 10 1
dans ses bouquins
alors je vais y aller en premier et mon
dieu je mange hésite entre b ou c mais
je vais m'aventurer dessus d'accord
c'est ça cette fois c'est ça cette fois
c'est donc c'est pour maryse là pas de
réponse seule chose c'est ça j'allais
abb 4 1 5 fois sur 10 quand on ne
s'aperçoit pas qu'on a été piqué ok on
voit pas cet influent rouge est bien la
bonne réponse vous perdez tous vos
points cellule a fait 3 fois 20 à 30%
des coques et ça hop c'est peut-être que
dans dix ans on dira différemment on
dira c'était dans 50 à 60% des cas non
sens ne percevait pas les choses
évoluent rapidement recherché ce que j
ai avant d'aller vers une personne qui
connaît bien ce problème des gens qui
sont atteints par la maladie je voulais
vous proposer au niveau du traitement ce
qui est le plus nouveau
si vous voulez et c'est assez
controversé vous connaissez amir khadir
vous irez de l'ue et week ends à nice un
kiki et amir khadir pour vous paroles
québec solidaire est atteint 2
de 6 à 20 qui s'appelait l'union des
forces populaires ça sert de salle et de
la politique qui va il est médecin
traitant qui veut toujours faire poster
j'allais vous le dire je pense que
jamais arrêté et il a toute une
réputation c'est un infectiologue
microbiologiste le besoin pierre le
gardeur ça c'est à terrebonne terrebonne
sait où alain staub montréal
hors de l'île n'en reste très bien alors
si vous voulez abandonner vers notre
entrevue
on va aller vers cette cette vidéo j'ai
appelé ça médicaments et c'est amir
khadir qui nous explique ce qu'il te
fais exactement pour essayer de de
remettre sur rails la vie de ces gens
qui sont atteints par la maladie la
maladie de lyme
on va écouter son ensemble cessé de
radio canada c'est assez court ça mais
ça nous met sur une piste avec laquelle
on pourra incapable de marcher il y a
quelques mois
rémi fortin peut maintenant descendre
facilement les marches de son balcon
antibiotiques partie biotique je m'en
fous je veux guérir
je veux surtout guéri mais enfin écoutez
on a fait tout les tests majeurs au
québec il ya personne qui verriez bond
mais attention disent plusieurs experts
l'efficacité de ce traitement est loin
d'être prouvée et consommer des
antibiotiques pendant plus de 28 jours
pourrait entraîner des conséquences
désastreuses mais aussi un paquet
d'autres effets secondaires qui sont
liées aux antibiotiques des risques
d'allergies des risques de problèmes
hépatiques des réseaux développement
aussi bactéries multirésistantes le
docteur amir khadir se défend de jouer à
l'apprenti sorcier
le fait que les passions été abondamment
et veste ig et pour d'autres maladies
que ça soit la sclérose en plaques
que ce soit les maladies auto immunes et
que le résultat de ces analyses de ces
traitements sont des culs de sac qui
confine les patients à une détresse
aider à des souffrances importantes
là on entame en toute connaissance de
cause et avec le consentement des
patients
ce qu'on appelle un traitement test pour
savoir si les patients peuvent répondre
à des entités de son coût alors la star
un portage du mois de juin de cette
année il nous dit par radio canada et on
dit que les gens dans la détresse vont
en allemagne en suisse à la recherche de
traitements et au canada ils vont vers
les etats unis c'est vrai ouais t'as
fait donc ce qui occasionne des dépenses
considérables et on parle d'extrême
faiblesse dans plusieurs cas des gens
qui sont extrêmement fermes qui peuvent
plus vaquer aux occupations de la vie
quotidienne et c'est des incidences sur
le coeur ça fait penser des grands
problèmes
ça peut causer à long terme des crises
cardiaques mais dr khadir a dit qu'elle
fut très important c'est à dire qu'on
essaye de dépister d'autres maladies
avant d'arriver à ça parce que dans mon
cas je suis atteinte d'une maladie auto
immune et au début ça aurait pu
ressembler les symptômes
alors c'est parce que c'est très
important daly par élimination pour bien
cibler ceux dont on est atteint en
attendant l'arrivée de notre prochain
invité on l'a régime indiquera d'aix
elle sera disponible
nous avons dit de petits détails
techniques à régler je vais vous
proposer notre vidéo du grossiste parce
que je sais que beaucoup de gens qui
nous écoutent en ce moment et qui
voudraient ça
comment avoir plus d'informations c'est
assez simple j'ai dans la vidéo numéro 6
on a ajouté à la page web de tam-tam
canada cette semaine une série de
reportages qu'on va regarder ensemble
l'instant avec des titres parfois un peu
imaginatif ça c'est la page de tintin
d'accord la page modèle je voulais c'est
pas celle d'aujourd'hui mais ça le sera
bientôt
voilà découvrez nos archives sur le même
sujet alors on a quand je vous parlais
de titres imaginatif je discutais allait
revenir
- mobilisation contre la maladie de lyme
maladie de lyme gueule sic pas très chic
et traitements très choc je lis à
détecter que la maladie de lyme est une
bombe à retardement
c'est bien choisi mort du découvreur de
la maladie de lyme présente de plus en
plus au canada oui on va aller voir ça
c'est en 2014
alors pour ceux qui sont intéressés
l'année 2014
et d'ailleurs vous lirez ça c'est
passionnant comment il a découvert c'est
une
c'est une maladie existe depuis 100 ans
des centaines d'années mais lui même à
10 nadia ça c'est spécial et il est mort
d'une maladie qui ressemblait ont parlé
des symptômes qui s'apparentent des fois
maladie du parkinson et il pensait qu'il
était lui même atteint de la maladie de
lyme est le moule la messe qu'il vient
d'où ce pour quoi on a délaissé les
témoins états unis à dakar
là où on l'a identifié là on a dit ah ça
c'est une drôle de maladie ça c'est un
peu je sais pas qu'elle avait
personnalisé 66 début des années
soixante dix mille souvenirs sont bons
qui date d'à peu près il ya deux jours
bon alors on n'atteint toujours notre
invité c'est bien car je vais demander à
la régie est-ce que c'est fait signe que
oui oui ce jour on a les prêts pour
notre troisième jeu dont elle est on va
on va régler ça avant ça
alors vous me rappelez les scores ont
fait ou cinq ans dans votre cas oui
vertus vous avez perdu cinq ans moi je
fais passer à 70 soit cup
qu'est-ce que j'ai été à 80,4 oui ouais
parce qu'elle devient ok alors on aura
peut-être 0 0 et rend dans quelques mois
quelques prédictions le malin plaisir
vous induire un écart alors il ya un
bout de temps c'était de la championne
alors quand je dis un bout de temps ça
fait des mois
voici notre troisième question veulent
afficher sur l'écran dans la vidéo qu'on
vient vous présenter à l'instant
étiez-vous attentif
combien d'articles de rci sur la maladie
de lyme était affichée pour le plaisir
disons que ça passait pas malgré son
départ
si vous n'êtes pas attention alors
est-ce que c'était cinq articles étaient
affichés sur cette sortie finalement la
partie s'est dit bon j'ai dit est ce que
j'y vais au milieu où je fais comment je
vais faire quand même en baisse parce
que si vous alliez au milieu peut-être
qu'on aurait un gagnant j'aimerais
changer ma réponse je vais aller avec le
b vous allez avec le billet ils brisent
félicitations c'est recommandé
oui parce que lui l'arrêt ok je
comprends donc c'est la bonne réponse cp
si jeune et si je n'ai pas aimé le
pauvre homme en la victoire
ben non bon y'a quand même un peu mais
c'est pas une victoire de musique je ne
peux alors c'est commencé quand je sais
pas moi j'ai toujours cette analogie de
la vie ok c'est d'atterrir et puis l'on
n'arrive il ment commence à manquer de
pc le pilote se dit bon je pense que je
vais faire le tour je pourrais pas
atterrir je demandais la tour de
contrôle si on a notre invité deuxième
unité sky présente travailler là-dessus
forme parfaite parce que c'est moi j'ai
une histoire privée et j'ai fait du
planeur alors la différence entre voler
un avion qui a un moteur c'est que c'est
vraiment le moteur qui nous propulse
mais c'est quand même des ailes qui nous
soutiennent
parce qu'il n'ya pas ailleurs l'air qui
voyagent sur le dessus des voyages plus
vite dans ce sens exactement il si cette
attaque et je me ferai toujours je
faisais mon cours des pc mon examen des
pilotes privés et là la personne qui me
donne un examen et 10 coupes ton moteur
gdi pas de problème parce que j'ai fait
du plana samoter alors je dis pas de
problème
où voulez-vous que je pose l'avion alors
j'ai dit ok je regardais direction du
vin on regarde le chien là bas en savoie
plaute caisse 500 pi2 correct et c'est
beau on a remis les gaz
on est reparti le poison de tv parce que
lorsqu'on fait du planeur on était
depuis c'est comme un atterrissage
urgence à chaque fois on peut pas se
tromper parce qu a pas de matière pour
nous sauver
alors faut apprendre à juger de la
vitesse la distance et du vent si vous
le permettez nous allons maintenant
avoir notre invité non pas sur ce 4 mai
sur téléphone il ya pas tellement
longtemps était on avait un téléphone
accroché
ouais là maintenant et est accroché au
téléphone alors annie aussi président de
l'association québécoise de la maladie
de lyme est avec nous peut-être que
notre régie pourra trouver des images de
la ligne venir ou si pendant que nous
oui bravo
alors je répète c'est l'association
québécoise la maladie de lyme mais on
lui parle je pense qu'il est dans la
région de québec madame rossi bonjour
oui bonjour est ce que vous nous voyez
elles n'ont pas pour l'instant le voit
pas ces deux heures écoutez on vient
d'avoir quelques informations de base
avec un spécialiste de la santé publique
au québec
vous vous intéressez beaucoup à la
situation sur le terrain aux gens qui en
cette maladie là vous êtes une personne
vers qui on se tourne lorsqu'on a un
problème où se situe votre travail
présentement au niveau de l'association
commun comment ce que vous faites ça
présentement ben écoute et l'association
québécoise de la maladie de lyme
elle existe en fait depuis plus de six
ans c'est une association qui est né en
fait don d'un besoin en fait des gens
qui sont atteints par la maladie de lyme
ou concernés par ce que il vivait des
problématiques dans le système médical
en lien avec cette maladie
donc c'est un regroupement de gens
malades
kiki tendance et de faire des actions et
de faire du faire en sorte qu' un
changement qui survient par rapport à la
prise en charge de cette maladie au
québec on offre aussi du soutien aux
gens qui sont atteints de la maladie on
leur donne de l'information
on offre du support de l'entr'aide en
fait on fait plusieurs actions voilà
vous aussi tout ce que voulait dire par
changement dans la brise en jambes
bah écoutez et comme vous l'avez
mentionné un peu plus tôt parce que j'ai
écouté la première partie de votre
entrevue il ya effectivement une
problématique avec cette maladie en fait
c'est une maladie qui se retrouve au
coeur d'une controverse médicale dans un
premier temps pour la phase d'une
chronique de la maladie mais il ya aussi
une problématique
en fait pour nous au québec en lien avec
la phase précoce est disséminée qu'on
appelle ou puisque c'est une maladie qui
est émergente au québec depuis quelques
années bien qu'elle existe depuis
longtemps cette maladie se soigne à une
problématique de prise en charge en fait
souvent des gens vont se présenter avec
des symptômes de la maladie des signes
apparents et ils seront pas de
diagnostiquer pour différentes raisons
là c'est sûr que c'est on pourrait
expliquer beaucoup de situations dans
ses yeux beaucoup de situations qui sont
portées nous à l'association à notre
attention et de ce c en 2018 nous on a
sollicité la la part du gouvernement ici
ans et en déposant une pétition pour qui
a justement des actions au niveau
gouvernemental pour une meilleure prise
en charge de la maladie en 2008 lancé en
mars 2008 yeux une commission
parlementaire sur le sujet de la maladie
de lyme
il ya beaucoup d'éléments qui sont
ressortis et iodée en fait des
recommandations qui ont été émises pour
justement qui est du changement avec la
maladie est ce que ça veut dire que les
gens qui pourraient être susceptibles
d'être affectés va diriger vers des
médecins particuliers qui connaissent
bien les symptômes ou cette maladie
certains cas a priori les médecins
spécialistes
sorel l'infectiologue microbiologie mais
pour l'instant la maladie en phase
primaire et secondaire mais c'est la fin
des soucis à tout l'ensemble les
médecins première lit par un spécialiste
bombes pouvant le délais d'attentes bien
quand fx légistes se doit d'être rapide
mais la maladie de l'âme comme on le
disait plus elle examine ce ghetto est
prise en charge rapidement meilleures
sont les chances que les gens puissent
se sortir de la maladie en fédérale 2
qui la maladie
donc on a besoin que tout le système
soit médical fois fois l'eau disponible
il faut que ça se fasse rapidement
donc concrètement ça vous parlais tout à
l'heure d'action gouvernemental de vous
aimeriez qu'ils soient prises données
dont des exemples que les actions l'a
écoutée déjà dans un premier temps suite
à la contre la commission parlementaire
il ya ici au québec l'un du national
d'excellence en santé et services
sociaux qui a été mandatée justement de
faire la lumière entourant tout
tout en fait toute la problématique de
la maladie de lyme en fait de de
consulter les patients de consulter les
professionnels la santé et de faire une
revue systématique la 2d artix en fait
des études scientifiques
la première phase de leur travaux vient
de sortir ce 28 mai dernier et nous on
est dans l'ensemble ça s'est bien que
tout ce qu'on ce qu'on demande en scène
ne pas été mis de l'avant mais il ya un
gros travail qui a été fait justement
pour dénoncer pour améliorer des choses
il ya une reconnaissance que la maladie
de lyme peut être contracté par tous sur
l'ensemble du territoire et pas
seulement dans les zones
oui à des ondes de tendinite mais le
risque demeure partout donc les médecins
partout doivent être vigilants et aussi
un peu plus tôt on parlait que de la
façon dont est investi la maladie de
lyme étaient basées majoritairement sur
les rythmes qui apparaît dans les
travaux de l'inr ce qui va ressortir
c'est que ce n'est pas vrai que tous les
patients d'un malade lines vont avoir un
érythème il ya un grand nombre de
personnes qui meurent nantes mais qui
vont avoir les symptômes mais qui auront
pas la marque
donc ça c'est sûr ça manque le niveau de
difficulté du diagnostic mais il faut
pas non plus les maîtres de compte et
c'est quand il faut vraiment inférieur
il ya un superbe travail qui a été fait
et maintenant c'est la communauté
médicale doit se mettre à niveau par
rapport à toutes ces informations là et
faire en sorte que la station 5
milliards au québec madame roux si on va
se quitter l'atuge que je voulais vous
dire c'est que vous êtes une excellente
porte parole vraiment le chapeau à nous
on a l'expérience de parler des porte
parole c'est très bien expliqué avec des
faits et avec elle les études qui
portent là dessus donc c'est très clair
alors on a confiance en fait qui est
important de dire c'est qu'il ya une
deuxième phase des travaux qui
concernent la maladie chronique qui va
sortir en 2020 présentement l'unef est
en train de travailler sur ces travaux
là pourriez-vous nous contacter à ce
moment là on reprendra alors lol le fil
de la conversation
voilà on vous voit enfin en fait des
entrevues
vous êtes vous êtes vous si vous habitez
la campagne oui mais en fait moi je suis
dans la région de rimouski une région
qui est poids devant attendre dtcc et
pourtant c'est bien qu'elle ait eu la
maladie de lyme moi et toute ma famille
en fait ouf ça fait combien de personnes
soit au total elle a fait 4
alors c'est donc votre époux su que je
présume de la réponse a dit aimer deux
ans et ça c'est quelque chose
merci beaucoup madame moi aussi mais je
vous remercie par annie aussi des choses
que je ne savais pas on n'en avait pas
parlé je pense que s'intéresse beaucoup
à 10 autres personnes
c'est quelqu'un qui donne ce soir puis
c'est intéressant parce qu'il ya toute
la question de est ce qu'on est capable
d'avoir un congé de maladie notre
employeur si on a une maladie qui est
difficilement diagnostiquée alors à lire
aussi président de l'association
québécoise de la maladie de lyme
c'est à cette émission normalement
laon vous présenter l'image de la
semaine vous savez que normalement on
jeu on joue je réponds à faire ou par
non je pense que cette semaine vous
devinez quelle est l'image de la semaine
tutelle et non pour pour nos gens qui
sont eux qui nous regarde là qui sont à
l'extérieur de radio canada
international ce ne serait pas l'image
la semaine mais pour nous seul et ça
vous donne une idée tout à fait d'accord
dont les initiales sont ces cas voilà si
vous voulez on va regarder ces images de
carmel qu'il met ni quelques années
quelqu'un me pardonnez moi on va sans
musique
on n'a pas besoin de musées comme
regardez notre vidéo qu'on a préparé
elle est décédée
c'était mardi et puis à 72 halal à
savoir 62 ans le mois prochain
une journaliste qui a travaillé à radio
canada international pendant plusieurs
années est ce que quelqu'un se souvient
du nombre d'années douze années louis tu
voudrais c'est dit et qu'on va continuer
à regarder les images parce qu'il ya des
choses que les on revient nous dit-on ce
centre qui a travaillé à la bbc qui
animait le téléjournal le soir 27
on va voir une image de la news wa que
vous allez voir quelques années plus
jeune dans les années 90 la voilà et
puis elle revenait d'europe apparemment
là beaucoup aimer l'europe elle est
revenue s'établir à montréal qu'elle
adorait on a diagnostiqué un cancer il
ya six semaines
donc elle est partie vite très vite la
voilà à tam tam tam canada mais dont une
femme ou une femme avec une voix
extraordinaire qui avait une façon
d'interviewer les gens et je lisais dans
les hommages qu'on lui rendait que elle
était une raconteuse d'histoires
storyteller elle était vraiment capable
de raconter une histoire et que ce soit
intéressant et qu'on ait le goût
d'écouter quelle que soit la longueur du
reportage ou de ce qu'elle faisait des
entrevues et puis on quand vous voulez
parler elle est à l'écouté
c'est exactement ce que j'avais dit on
parle d'elle comme une storyteller mais
c'était à l'écouté vraiment bien quand
on lui parlait et la personne qui a
écrit l'article en civil
est avait l'impression que c'était juste
toi qui était important pour en ce
moment pour éviter absolument
comme ça j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir à
travailler avec karma dans l'interface
parce que je travaillais aussi pas mal
en anglais et j'allais travailler avec
elle parfois notamment quand elle
animait link et est aussi hors antenne
quand on se taquinait beaucoup sur
l'irlande parce que elle est de souche
irlandaise qu'un kamer et on a eu ces
elle elle me manquera beaucoup
c'est vraiment un choc pour tous deux
filles
c'est là que j'avais un point commun
avec elle parce que ma grand mère
s'appelle riggins du caractère et quand
mr la valeur très douce tous explique
maryse tous espèrent route reste écoutez
je dirais que l'équipe technique on lui
donne derrière des rideaux aujourd'hui
et qui lui a quand même fait des années
qu'on n'a pas salué absolument là dessus
on se quitte et l'équipe technique vous
pouvez afficher vous ne vous avait pas
besoin de kong ou quand je vous forcent
la main vous avez c'est pas parce que
l'on fait en complète souvent les
émissions sans dire merci merci et là je
pense que c'est pourquoi ils se diraient
pas merci humains ils n'ont pas préparé
c'est pas prêt pas prêt écoutez quand ça
sera prêt vous enverrai une lettre je
pense ce soit à peu près cette semaine
mais la semaine prochaine on vous le
promet il vous le promettre ce sera prêt
alors nous toute l'équipe